noch läuft der Betrieb in der
Möbelmanufaktur von tebocho Kulu in
Johannesburg doch bald wird der Strom
abgestellt laut shading nennt sich das
der Strom wird rationiert weil der Staat
nicht genug erzeugen kann die
Auswirkungen dramatisch
Katastrophe es ist eine Katastrophe
wirtschaftlich gesprochen es bedeutet
den Verlust von Einkommen und Umsatz und
wirkt sich massiv auf die Ertragskraft
aus
an diesem Tag fällt der Strom dreimal
für je zweieinhalb Stunden aus so wie in
diesem Moment dann geht's nur noch mit
Generator
doch der kostet durch den Krieg in der
Ukraine sind die Preise für Treibstoff
weiter gestiegen coole und seine Leute
arbeiten teilweise nachts unterm
Wochenende eben dann wenn Strom da ist
doch das alles macht die Produktion
teurer seine Kunden haben dafür kein
Verständnis
wenn du erklärst dass die
Produktionskosten höher geworden sind
als ursprünglich vereinbart dass du
alleine um das Produkt herzustellen ein
Minus von 30% machst das interessiert
sie nicht denn wir hatten eine
Vereinbarung
kann seine Mitarbeiter derzeit nur
eingeschränkt oder mit Verspätung
bezahlen und an jedem Mitarbeiter hängt
eine Familie die ernährt werden muss das
alles zehrt an ihm
ich liebe meine Leute meine Arbeit ich
liebe was ich tue und wenn du etwas mit
Leidenschaft machst wenn du etwas liebst
und es enttäuscht dich dann wirst Du
fast verrückt
es treibt dich fast an den Punkt
Selbstmord zu begehen
er hat Angst dass sein Betrieb auf Dauer
so nicht überleben kann
in der Wirtschaftsmetropole Johannesburg
haben die Menschen die Nase voll von den
ständigen Stromausfällen und das nicht
nur weil sie teilweise die Existenz
gefährden die Stromausfälle bringen das
Leben aus dem Rhythmus und dann ist da
noch der Lärm der Generatoren ob
tagsüber oder mitten in der Nacht es ist
zermürbend
die Ampeln sind aus
ja wenn sie nicht funktionieren musst du
zwei Stunden früher los das ist zu viel
das ärgert mich deshalb bin ich
verspätet
wenn du von zu Hause arbeitest ist es
schwer damit umzugehen du kannst nicht
liefern bist nicht effizient
ich weiß nicht was aber Sie müssen es
lösen denn es trifft uns alle sehr
die Stromausfälle gibt es schon seit
Jahren doch noch nie war es so schlimm
wie jetzt Grund sind langjährige
Misswirtschaft und Korruption beim
staatlichen Stromkonzern es kommen erst
vor kurzem wurde Martina Coco verhaftet
der frühere es kommt Chef soll
umgerechnet mehr als 2 Millionen Euro in
die eigenen Taschen gewirtschaftet haben
der Vorwurf Korruption betrug Geldwäsche
die Gelder die so abgezweigt werden
fehlen bei der Instandhaltung und
Wartung von Kraftwerken und Stromnetzen
so kommt es zu den Blackouts an den
schmutzigen Geschäften sind zahlreiche
Personen beteiligt sie sitzen selbst den
Politik und Polizei und der Rest des
Landes sitzt im Dunkeln
wir müssen sicherstellen dass die
laufenden Ermittlungen auch Ergebnisse
liefern in Form von Gerichtsverfahren
dass die Schuldigen ausfindig gemacht
werden und gestohlene Güter zurückgeholt
werden das würde die Botschaft senden
dass es kommen kein Beute gut ist für
Menschen mit korrupten Absichten
was wir brauchen ist eine Säuberung von
ganz oben bis ganz unten
für den Moment bleibt den Südafrikaner
nur eines sich so gutes eben geht mit
den Stromausfällen zu arrangieren so wie
Familie krummmu das wichtigste die
elektronischen Geräte die man braucht
Aufladen solange noch Strom da ist über
die geplanten Ausfälle informiert eine
App
today heute sind es drei Stromausfälle
morgens um zwei um zehn und gleich von
18 Uhr bis halb neun darauf verlassen
wir uns wenn es darum geht wie oft und
wann der Strom ausfällt es ist ziemlich
präzise
mittlerweile kochen Sie mit Gas früher
musste im Notfall der Campingkocher ran
für den kühl- und Gefrierschrank ist ein
Ausfall von 2 bis 3 Stunden in der Regel
kein Problem ihre Erfahrung nach aber
ganz wichtig alternative Lichtquellen
sieh zu dass du dich als erstes um die
Beleuchtung kümmerst denn das kann dir
die Laune verderben
für einen Moment bleibt es dunkel als
der stromausfällt
dann gehen bei Familie kromu solange
Lichter an
das Leben geht weiter
das Gute ist dass ich mehr Zeit mit
meinen Kindern habe wir sind uns mehr
machen mehr gemeinsam weil nicht jeder
vor einem Bildschirm hängt
statt Fernsehen zu sehen spielen Sie
jetzt häufiger Brettspiele das sei
zumindest etwas Positives an der Misere
die ständigen Stromausfälle haben auch
zu einer Wasserkrise geführt
Johannesburg liegt auf 1.600 Metern das
Wasser für die Bewohner der Stadt muss
nach oben in die reservas gepumpt werden
durch die Stromausfälle laufen die
Pumpen aber nicht in dem Umfang wie es
nötig wäre das Resultat Wasserknappheit
die Lage in Johannesburg bleibt fragil
ein Ende der Krise ist nicht in Sicht